[music]
>> Uber is making a new super app push. The
company that has come to dominate
Western ride-hailing market has
partnered with Expedia
>> [music]
>> to allow users to book travel within its
app. The move forms part of a
longer-term ambition at Uber, which
wants to keep customers on its platform
by offering them a wide array of
services. The company expanded into food
delivery in 2019, quickly followed by
groceries and shopping, and well, now
travel. Uber chief executive Dara
Khosrowshahi says that the move of
Expedia is also designed to drive uptake
of the group's premium membership
scheme. The group already has more than
50 million paid subscribers to its Uber
One program, but it hopes that by
offering them a range of discounts, it
can drive uptake.
The only problem is that super apps have
had limited traction in Western markets,
where users seem to be tied to
individual services. And there are other
challenges on the horizon.
AI agents which can book travel and
undertake a range of tasks on behalf of
users all threaten to cut out middlemen
like Uber. Uber is responding by trying
to drive up engagement and entice users
to stay on its platform.